YUFENG GUO: A team
at Google set out
to make a game of
Pictionary more interesting
and ended up with the
world's largest doodling
dataset and a powerful machine
learning model to boot.
How did they do it?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to check out
the largest dataset
of hand-drawn doodles
and see what we can do with it.
"Quick, Draw!" was a
game that was initially
featured at Google I/O
in 2016 as a game where
one player would
be prompted to draw
a picture of an object
and the other player
would need to guess what it was,
just your standard Pictionary
game.
In 2017, the team took
that idea a step further
and used the Sketch-RNN
model from the Magenta team
at Google Research
to try to predict
what the player was
drawing in real time
instead requiring
a second player.
The game is now available
online and has collected
millions of hand-drawn doodles.
Let's take a look at
some of the drawings that
have come out of "Quick, Draw!"
Here we see some
broccoli being drawn
by many different players.
Oceans are depicted in
slightly different ways
by different players
all over the world.
It's just a lot of fun
to browse the dataset.
And if you find something
that seems out of place,
you can fix it right
there on the page
and make the data
better for everyone.
In fact, the team has
open-sourced this data
and in a variety of formats.
You can learn more
at their GitHub page.
There are four formats.
First up is the raw files
themselves, stored in .ndjson.
These files encode the full set
of information for each doodle.
It contains timing
information for every stroke
of every picture drawn.
And there's also a
simplified version
stored in the same format, which
has some pre-processing applied
to help normalize the data.
This simplified version is also
available as a binary format
for more efficient
storage and transfer.
And it comes with
examples of how
to read out these binary files
using both Python and Node.js.
The fourth format
is interesting.
It takes in the simplified
data and renders it as 28-by-28
grayscale bitmap in
NumPy .npy format.
You can load it using np.load().
Why 28-by-28 pixels?
Well, it's a perfect replacement
for any existing code you might
have for processing MNIST data.
So if you're looking
for something fancier
than 10 hand-written digits,
you can try processing
over 300 different classes
of hand-drawn doodles.
So ready to take on
that dataset and train
your own recurrent neural net?
Check out the
tutorial I've linked
in the description down below.
And if you're want to
explore the data some more,
you can visualize the "Quick,
Draw!" dataset using Facets.
The Facets team has
taken the liberty
of hosting the data online
and even given us some presets
to play around with.
We can load up
some random chairs
and see how different
players drew the chairs
from all over the world.
We can also see
which drawings were
recognized as chairs, which
ones didn't quite make the cut.
There's a number of
preset views that
are also worth
playing around with
and serve as great starting
points for further exploration
and analysis.
I have one final idea for what
you can do with this dataset.
I noticed that while there
are hexagons and pandas,
there aren't any pentagons
or koalas in the dataset.
You can create a new class
to extend this dataset
and train your
model to recognize,
not only in the many different
classes already present,
but also in your own
custom image class.
Whether it's your company logo,
school emblem, or something
else entirely, make
the dataset your own.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed
it, please like it
and consider subscribing to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out the
"Quick, Draw!" dataset
and see what insights
you can glean from it.